(jumping)
- Often times you hear people say
that they've done double dutch
but most people have
never experienced what
double dutch is now.
It's a competitive sport.
You're jumping so that
you'll be able to win.
(dramatic music)
(hip hop music)
My name is Khnaue Robinson.
I'm a part of Floyd
Little Double Dutch team
which is located in Newark, New Jersey.
I'm 17 years old and I've
been jumping double dutch
for five years.
I practice with the double
dutch team three times a week.
We compete four times a year
and it leads up to the World Competition
and my team has 19 World
Championship titles.
We're currently in competition season
and everyone is aiming to win the trophy.
Joining double dutch,
it gave me a safe place,
it gave me a home.
This isn't just jumping rope.
I was born and raised
in Newark, New Jersey
and Newark is a city where
a lot of violence occurs.
It's not always safe to be outside.
A lot of shooting happening.
I just never know what to expect.
(bus engine rumbles)
Growing up I didn't have
the mother relationship
with my own mother so I feel
like coming to double dutch
has really opened my eyes and let me know
that there is people who care about me.
I have a support system
whenever I need it.
Double dutch is where I need to be.
(school bell buzzes)
(metal clinks)
It takes a person with endurance.
It take a person with strength.
It takes a person with a positive attitude
in order to be a winner,
in order to be that person
who knows how to jump.
In double dutch competition,
the most important component
of double dutch is speed.
That's how fast a jumper
in the rope can jump.
(tapping)
Giving the support to the jumper is a job
that's really important to me
because growing up I
didn't have that support
and I know that I want to give the support
that I never had to the
person who's in the rope
so they can know that no matter
how many mistakes you did
you can come back from it.
You're still gonna be a
winner at the end of the day.
They have what it takes
to win the tournament.
(hip hop music)